dimanche 23 juin 9h30 160 coureurs se
sont réunis au pied de la colline
d'elancourt pour participer à la 21e
édition de la revancharde une course de
vtt qui se tiendra cette année sous des
températures estivales et pour dompter
au mieux le thermomètre chacun a sa
technique
moi c'est déjà d'essayer de finir et pas
me cramer tout de suite au départ pour
pouvoir finir proprement parce que c'est
quand même assez long
kazim heure et demie il faut ménager la
monture comme on dit qui veut aller loin
ménage sa monture donc là ça va être les
premiers tours un peu en dedans et après
on verra vers la fin sont peu un peu
développé les les chevaux cette année un
tracé de 5 9 km a été imaginé par les
organisateurs sur le futur site
olympique des compétitions de vtt en
2024 niveau difficulté assez élevé comme
voilà après fo fo est assez technique
par endroit il ya un peu de roullens
faut savoir faire du vtt par endroits je
sais que voilà là où il s'aventure avec
leurs vélos moi je descendrai je
descendrai à côté c'est sûr et certain
n'ont pas réussi à surmonter les
difficultés ayant dû s'arrêter dès le
deuxième tour
c'est super difficile mais j'ai pas du
tout à condition pour voilà c'est
simplement ça je serais déçu si c'était
sur une carte
lui a bien boucler ses cinq tours
nicolas 10 mai de gif-sur-yvette
remporte cette édition hugo parmentier
parti devant il y avait 20 à 30 secondes
d'avancé suite avec cédric chartier on
est revenus tous les deux petit à petit
et voilà ensuite on a fait le petit
groupe de trois et ensuite bord on s'est
attaqué juste dans la fin la dernière
bosse en parallèle l'événement a permis
de récolter près de 2500 euros en faveur
des orphelins des sapeurs pompiers
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition